eight minutes left here on 4th phileas
so now it's down to the three short try
to draw a foul on Joe
here's Donovan stop a pot rainbow get up
you talk transition on the other end
Mitchell pulls up for pick three and
they says come on let's go it's time
outside Crowder is a jazz continue to
come back down by ten Donovan Drive
Superman flying in hole 4 - right back
at you [ __ ]
his 34th point of the knife a huge
difference when you have no Lopez and no
Yanis in the ballgame Mitchell picks up
Connaughton one-on-one uses that screen
behaves floater it's up jazz earn a nice
offensive rhythm right now here's
Mitchell pops it floats it he went off
the wrong leg made it look awkward but
was able to finish slows the tempo this
crowd has not taken a seat
gilja silva picks up Mitchell three ball
it's a star he is a star he's made it to
the big stage now Donovan backs out
Connaughton gives him space he'll take
the three
[Applause]
just pulls up two feet outside the
three-point arc with the honest
switching out on them
he's got the touch he's got the feel
holds the follow-through